i believe you made your first feature
film in 2013.
did you think upon making that your life
was going to change
i guess if i were to ever have a period
of my life where i did have a chip on my
shoulder it was
in 2012 making that movie um
i i i didn't really i didn't know what
was gonna happen with it i
i was very much focused on just making a
movie that i wanted to make and had
zero intention of trying to make
something marketable
or or anything all i wanted out of it
was
sort of just you know i just wanted to
open a door and have
maybe an agent that can help me make my
next movie
or garner the attention of some
investors that would finance the next
movie
uh while making it it was an absolute
blast
uh and i definitely hope for the best i
didn't if you were to actually ask me
truthfully if i thought this was gonna
be my big break i'd probably say
no i don't think so but i just sort of
wanted to
prove to myself that i could make a
coherent
story and and i think i successfully did
that
at least you know when i was 20 23 years
old or so
do you really think that's a chip on
your shoulder or more just
creative longing just wanting to make
something
it was probably probably more creative
longing i mean i
it wasn't like in a cocky way i of
course
hoped that we would get in a sundance
and make a million dollars and
there was a small part of my mind that
thought that could happen i could see
that happening
now i don't really think in that way so
so when i was younger i definitely you
know the whole sundance dream
and selling your movie for for millions
and millions of dollars was
it was much more of a possibility in my
mind
back then whereas now it might happen
but i don't even
i don't even think about that now now i
focus so much more on
the actual content i'm trying to make
and just making the best possible movie
i can
would you advise other first-time
filmmakers not just a short but a
feature
that would be really more of a again
cliche term but a passion project
rather than aiming for this incredible
distribution deal
that's that's a very difficult question
to answer
and i know i'm sure a lot of people will
watch this and and i want to i want to
be careful with my word choice because i
don't want to like lead anyone down the
wrong path
um you know obviously everyone's
different
and personally i think it's important to
think you know about the business of it
and also think creatively just how
everything else
seems to be a balance in life you also
need the balance of business and
creative
like you at least if if you want to make
a living
doing this and only this personally i
think that's
really important um there are plenty of
people who i
who i you know look up to that not once
have ever thought about the business
part of things in fact they despise it
and they've only focused on the
creative part of it and and that's
worked out
well for them and then there's plenty of
people that only focus on the business
and you watch their movie and you can
tell but the business is really working
out and the the creativity part of it
kind of suffers
for me i like to keep both in mind all
the time
when i'm actually on set or when i'm
actually in front of my computer writing
i first and foremost i do my best to
compartmentalize and i
i just focus on the story and what it is
that i'm actually writing about
what it is i want to say and then when
we go through the revision stage it's
like all right well this might be more
relatable or we might be able to
actually
call this a horror film if we add a few
more you know jump scares or you know
just sort of add to it fluff it up to
sort of take your original creative
vision
and make it a little bit more marketable
so you can make money and do it again
what mistakes did you make with 15 north
that have always stuck with you that
then going forward with a new project
you always remember those mistakes and
try to correct anything whether it's in
pre-production post
i think i spent too much on
post-production i think i
i think i i realized later on that i
could actually do a lot more
myself at least in that small of a
budget
i could do a lot more uh instead of you
know spending money and
hiring you know someone else to do
certain things
um although then again the entire
landscape has changed and you're able to
do so much more from home
now than you were just seven years ago
i'm trying to think of of the biggest
mistake i would say the biggest mistake
that i made on my first movie
was not spending enough time on the
script
i definitely approached the entire
project
with this attitude of i just want to
make a movie i want to make it
real i'm just going to keep the cameras
rolling and
you know get natural performances it's
very sort of mumble core style
and i think that that is good but i
didn't prepare enough i feel like i
could have
fleshed out the story a lot more with
you know just
really focus on a more traditional
three-act structure
and and focus on writing
characters with more depth and and that
sort of thing
if there was one thing i could do over
again that would probably be it is just
spend more time focusing on the actual
script
do you think that prompted your youtube
channel because you give such helpful
tips
with your channel do you think that
prompted you to want to start it or no
certainly i mean i i think the
the content i'm putting out on on my
youtube channels is basically just
everything i wanted to see you know when
i was
when i was a few years younger i wanted
to see people
creating content from home by themselves
and
i enjoy that i love seeing people and
what they're able to do
without big studios behind them uh
would i take a studio job of course
but i really get a kick out of this
just home brewed you know do-it-yourself
kind of
approach i think
your top video um is about the using um
the drawing aspect in adobe oh yeah
the the scribble animation that's funny
did you know that would be so popular
uh no not not really i mean i know it's
a it's a popular effect
um but yeah
with that kind of thing you never really
know it's gonna be popular
with our other channel you know social
house films that's a lot more
cut and dry you know if you if you make
a short horror film
and it looks pretty and the monster
looks scary
then it's probably gonna do pretty well
uh these tutorials it's it's hard to
sort of be on the pulse of what
effect is going to be you know the most
desirable
now that now that tick tock is a thing
you know a lot of people are trying to
like create their own effects at home
and
and so i never know what that next thing
is going to be
you